you're not living on the edge you're
taking up too much space I put up with
two extremely naughty boys on a regular
basis my kids that's a talent I would
say my hope from the future is at aj+
rocks and hopefully make a difference in
the world it's an opportunity to tell
stories important stories to an audience
that generally tends to be overlooked
disenfranchised by a lot of the bigger
major media players that have the
opportunity to tell stories but tend not
to speak to that audience in a way that
is deserving for that audience the
younger audience subscribe on YouTube
follow us on Twitter and like us on
Facebook